[MUSIC PLAYING]
LAURENCE MORONEY: Hi,
everybody, and welcome to Coffee
With a Googler.
Today, I'm in Sydney, Australia,
in a music room in the Google
office to chat with Casey
Whitelaw, who is an engineering
director for Google Maps.
Welcome, Casey.
Thanks for being on the show.
CASEY WHITELAW: Thanks a lot.
It's a pleasure to be here.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
So tell us what
is it that you do as an
engineering director.
CASEY WHITELAW: The
teams that I work
with build Google Maps APIs.
So this means, basically, if
you see a Google map that's
not inside the
Google Maps app, then
that's probably served through
one of the APIs that we build.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So there's,
like, lots of geo-type data
that gets fed into lots
of different sources.
And that's what you're building.
CASEY WHITELAW:
Yeah, that's right.
So the most obvious examples
that you'll see, on the web
we have the web Maps API.
So you can put a map
in your web page.
And it's not just
a map, of course,
but it's drawing lines on
that map, and directions,
and Street View.
And basically, almost everything
that's in Google Maps itself,
you can put inside
your own web pages
and use to present
your own information.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK, cool.
CASEY WHITELAW: And you can take
all of that, the same things
that you can do with web Maps
API, and do that on Android
through Android MapView.
And also in iOS,
through iOS Maps SDK.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Cool.
Now, in working all this,
you must have some favorites.
CASEY WHITELAW:
There's so many APIs.
Right?
I mean, we haven't even
mentioned all of them yet.
Like, I mentioned web
and Android and iOS.
Everything that you get
through all of those, and even
some more things again, you
can get through web services.
And so this means that you can
use them directly with your web
server, or on a client that
you need to customize more.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CASEY WHITELAW: So the
range is really huge.
I think it's something you'll
see if you go to the dev site,
as well.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
CASEY WHITELAW: Something
which often strikes people
as being very simple,
that is actually, I think,
fascinatingly complex
is the Directions API.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CASEY WHITELAW: So
on the surface of it,
you're just moving.
You want to know how long
it's going to take you,
or how you should get
from point A to point B.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
CASEY WHITELAW: And so that
seems like a pretty simple API.
Right?
I'm going to give
you a source, I'm
going to give you a destination.
You tell me how it
is that I'm going
to go from one to the other.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
CASEY WHITELAW: But just
like in Google Maps,
this gets quite complicated.
The things that you can do with
this are quite complex, too.
So something that most
people don't realize
is that we use
live traffic data.
So that the ETAs
that you're getting
and the directions
that we're giving you
aren't the same,
depending on exactly when
it is that you request for.
So you can request a
specific time of day,
for example, and
get a travel time
that actually reflects that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I
love planning ahead.
Like, when I have to go
to the airport tomorrow,
I need to know now when
I would be leaving,
and that kind of stuff.
So I can actually feed in, I'm
going to the airport tomorrow
at this time.
What's the traffic
going to be like?
CASEY WHITELAW: And
if you're a developer,
and you're developing an
application for people
to get to an airport,
you can actually do that.
Right?
You can give them directions
if you know when they're
going to need to be traveling.
You can actually give them
directions and travel time,
together with showing
that on the Google Map.
That's for the time that you
know that they have to travel.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Exactly.
CASEY WHITELAW: And then that's
going to be synced to it.
So I think that's really cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And it's
not just driving, right?
There's also things like
public transport and walking.
CASEY WHITELAW: Public
transport, and walking,
and cycling.
So most of what you
can do on Google Maps,
you can do through
the API as well.
So that's one aspect of
it being richer than just
saying from here to there.
The multiple modes,
and the using traffic.
Including predicted
traffic, by the way.
So if you said, for
sometime in the future,
we'll use our models to
try and work out our best
estimate of the traffic.
And you can also do things like
multi-waypoint optimization.
So you can, if you
know that you have
to visit many different
locations, like maybe--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Stop
for a coffee on the way?
CASEY WHITELAW: Exactly.
It's like, come to Google,
have a coffee with me.
Then head out into the city,
and so forth, but you're
not sure exactly what
the best order is
in which to do those things.
You can actually just
send a set of waypoints,
and say, optimize.
And then we're going to
do the traveling salesman
problem for you.
Because we're Google, and
that's the kind of problem
we like solving.
And we'll do a traveling
salesman problem for you,
and actually
optimize your route,
so that you've got the most
efficient path through those.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Pretty cool.
CASEY WHITELAW:
Yeah, really cool.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So that efficient path is
based on traffic conditions,
and those type of--
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah, exactly.
And optimizes for travel
time, not just time, not just
distance, for example.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Now, not that
long ago, apps for geo and apps
for maps on your phone
used to be like a map.
Here's A, and here's B, and
here's how you get there,
but without all that kind
of location intelligence.
But now we're just seeing
more and more innovation, more
and more cool things happening.
What cool apps have you
seen that have excited you,
or inspired you?
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah,
in the location space.
So I saw one recently, which
was a great, kind of cute use
of location
information, which isn't
in itself very sophisticated.
But I think it's a great
example of, I think,
the democratization, really,
of location information.
So the app that I saw
is called platypusSPOT.
LAURENCE MORONEY: platypusSPOT?
CASEY WHITELAW: platypusSPOT.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CASEY WHITELAW: And so, it's
pretty Australian-focused.
You know, so the international
readers out there, viewers
out there--
so platypuses are a
relatively rare creature here
in Australia, and
there's plenty of people
who are interested
in finding them,
and then sharing when they do.
So it's basically
Instagram for--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
For platypuses.
CASEY WHITELAW: And
so what you do is,
you're out on a bushwalk.
Or maybe you're even in
the city or something,
at the Yarra River in Melbourne,
and you see a platypus.
And you can tag it.
You say, this is where I am.
Here's my photo of the
platypus, if you're lucky enough
to take a photo of one.
And that all gets logged.
So if you then want
to see a platypus,
you can see where
have platypuses
been sighted recently,
so I can go and find one.
But also, it's
building this database
behind the scenes,
which scientists can
use for other things as well.
So I've heard-- I'm
no expert in this--
that platypus is related
to water quality.
So platypus presence is related
to water quality in rivers.
So imagine--
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
CASEY WHITELAW: You can build
up some kind of location
intelligence information from--
LAURENCE MORONEY: Interesting.
CASEY WHITELAW: --from
these sightings.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So
they like clean water.
So if you see them,
you know that's where
this-- that's cool.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah.
LAURENCE MORONEY: So,
platypus metadata.
CASEY WHITELAW: And the
thing is, they would never--
if you didn't have a map
that you could use easily--
and if you wind back 10
years, pre-Google Maps,
because the Maps API
happened really early
on in the development
of Google Maps, too--
if you wind back the clock,
and there is no easy way
to show things on a
map on your own site,
you have no option
for how to do this.
So like, you can get
people to enter an address.
Where were you standing
when this happened?
And so the fact that--
LAURENCE MORONEY:
On a tiny keyboard.
CASEY WHITELAW: Exactly.
Well, I guess in those
days, you probably
would have had to carry your
computer around with you,
or wait 'till you got back.
LAURENCE MORONEY: I had one
of those 10-pound laptops.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah.
And so, now you have
a map that you can use
very easily inside your app.
Location information
from your phone,
which is pretty
accurate basically
everywhere in the world,
a camera, and some web
service that's collating
all of this for you.
It's just amazing.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Isn't it incredible?
The amount of intelligence
and data that's there, that--
but then, how people are
turning that into innovation,
and building really cool apps.
Like the platypusSPOT.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah.
And the other thing
I'm seeing, everyone's
seeing a lot at the moment,
is location-based games.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yes.
CASEY WHITELAW:
Obviously, there's
Pokemon GO, which has been
a huge hit everywhere.
And you can see
that building on top
of a model of the real world.
So there's a lot more that I
expect we'll see in the future.
We had a play-around with this--
I'm sure that you know about
this-- in Santa Tracker
last year.
So we had our own
location-based game
in there, which was a lot
of fun to put together
on top of Google Maps.
So that was a really great first
test for us, building that.
LAURENCE MORONEY: And
that whole concept
blew my mind, because to me
all of the innovation in gaming
was going into power.
You know, better and
better GPUs, higher frame
rate, higher resolution.
And then suddenly,
out of the blue,
some games came out that
changed the paradigm completely.
And it was getting
you off the sofa,
and going out and running
around in the real world.
And that's incredible.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah.
I think it just shows you what
you can do when you have access
to different kinds of data.
You can build different
experiences around it
than you could otherwise.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Right.
So, good APIs enable innovation.
CASEY WHITELAW:
Yeah, and things--
if we go back to the
platypusSPOT example,
this is never something-- as
much as I love platypuses,
it's never something that we're
going to build in Google Maps,
right?
Because we'd have to
build a platypus tracker,
and then we'd probably turn it
into a all things in the world
tracker by the time
it became something
that was in Google Maps.
And so it's just
not going to happen.
And so, if we were the only ones
building on top of Google Maps,
then platypusSPOT wouldn't
exist in the form that it is.
So it's great to have a
platform that other people can
build on top of and make it
part of their businesses.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
I mean, who would
have thought that we would think
of a platypus spotter, even?
Right?
But if there's somebody who's
really passionate about them,
or somebody who's
researching about them.
And this having an API
allows them to build a tool
that they could share with us.
CASEY WHITELAW: And we don't
need to think about it, either.
It doesn't need to
be important to us
for it to exist in the world.
I think it's something, which
is that there's a balance there.
We see a lot of people solving
the same kinds of problems
over and over again,
and using Maps.
To pick a very common online
example, if you've got a store,
you probably want to point out
to people where that store is.
And so that's
something that, yes,
we don't need to know
about your particular store
in order to make our Maps API.
But it's important
for us to understand
that this is a use case
that's important to people.
That many people are going
to use Maps to build a store
finder, and so we should
make that something
that's really easy to do.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Yup.
So if I'm a
developer, and I want
to build a store
finder for my store,
or I want to build
the next platypusSPOT
or whatever it is
type spotting app,
where should I get started?
What advice would you give me?
CASEY WHITELAW: So
go to the dev site.
There's lots of documentation.
There's sample code.
There's even some complete
applications that are on there.
You can get started
really quickly.
I would just say,
go check it out.
LAURENCE MORONEY: OK.
Download some source
code and start hacking.
CASEY WHITELAW: Yeah that's it.
LAURENCE MORONEY: Sounds good.
And that's
developers.google.com/maps,
right?
CASEY WHITELAW:
You're the expert.
LAURENCE MORONEY: It's
a beautiful thing.
Well, thank you so much, Casey.
It's been a lot of fun,
and I'm going to go check
out that platypus app.
CASEY WHITELAW:
Thank you, Laurence.
LAURENCE MORONEY:
Thanks, everybody,
for watching Coffee
With a Googler.
If you've got any
questions for me,
or if you have any
questions for Casey,
just please leave them
in the comments below.
And don't forget to hit
that subscribe button.
Thank you.
So visit
developers.google.com/maps
to learn more about all the
things you can do to build
location intelligence,
geo apps, Maps apps,
and all the great stuff
that we've spoken about.
To learn more, you can
also watch this series
called Geocasts, where we're
walking through building better
maps and building better apps.
And if you want to learn more
about Coffee With a Googler
and see more episodes, take
a look at our playlist here.